Uh, there's been a lot of discussion lately
about Pete Buddha judge partially because
he's polling better and also because he got
a ton of speaking time in the last democratic
debate, way more speaking time as we analyzed
then the level of polling support he had at
the time would have predicted.
And this is yet another sign that the establishment
and corporate legacy media are interested
in pushing, uh, the establishment centrist
candidates over other candidates.
But what I want to talk about today is how
pushing booted judge is actually a really
safe thing to do for the establishment.
And corporate media because you might think,
hold on a second.
If the establishment wants a centrist, they
should be pushing Biden.
He's already leading in the polls and you
might think not unreasonably, if the establishment
starts pushing mayor Pete, that could take
away support from Joe Biden and it could lead
to a Bernie nomination or it could lead to
a war in nomination.
So it's risky for the establishment to divide
support between booted judge and Biden if
what they ultimately want to do is prevent
Bernie or Warren from being the nominees,
which I think is pretty clear is what they
want to do.
But I don't believe this is the way it's actually
going to play out partially because remember
that the primary process doesn't happen all
at once.
And partially because people getting comfortable
with Buddha judge helps them get comfortable
with Biden too.
So I'll explain to you how this all works.
As a reminder, P Buddha judge is now pulling
an average of between about 11 and 12 including
in one poll, 16% way up.
He was at 4% four and a half percent a few
months ago.
So he has a roughly tripled his support.
Now in the meantime we have seen both Bernie
and Elizabeth Warren fall in the polls.
Here is how pushing Buddha judge is safe for
the establishment and in the end it probably
helps Biden retain his spot at the top of
the polling by pushing Buddha judge the establishment
is generally pushing establishment centrism
over the ideology of folks like Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren.
So once you are in the mindset, once you're
in the universe of considering Pete, Buddha,
judge, his general ideology becomes sort of
your status quo starting point, almost a foregone
conclusion.
But you might start to say, you know, I'm
all in with Buddha judges' ideology, but is
he electable?
Is he too young?
Does he have enough experience merely having
been mayor of South bend, Indiana.
But that's the, the the strategy.
If you become comfortable with booted judge
on policy, thanks to the establishment pushing
him and you vote for him in a primary and
maybe he wins some early primaries and has
a path to the nomination, even if he doesn't
win, your natural transition is to Joe Biden.
Once you are in the universe of centrism,
once you've bought that bill of goods as the
ideology that you want to support for the
democratic primary, if you start to question
Buddha judge, because of his lack of experience
or age or other factors and then you say,
I'm going to look for somebody else.
The obvious choice becomes Biden.
Biden is a centrist like Buddha judge with
more experience and having held more prominent
political office and what I mean by the way,
but by, when I say the obvious choices, Biden,
I don't mean the obvious choice for me.
I don't mean the obvious choice for Progressive's.
I mean once you want centrism but with more
experience than mayor Pete.
It's a very easy transition to go over to
supporting Joe Biden going booted judge to
Bernie or even booted judge to Warren is less
of a smooth transition and this is why corporate
legacy media pushing Pete, Buddha judge where
it's unclear if Biden's got it together.
His performances and debates haven't been
good.
It's win-win.
Either you push Buddha judge as the a Biden
alternative and prevent people from going
to Warren or Bernie or you simply are pushing
centrism and in the end you end up reinforcing
Joe Biden and really what you want to do if
you're the establishment corporate legacy
media and the DNC insiders, you want to deny
Bernie the nomination.
You want to deny Elizabeth warrantee the nomination.
Let me know what you think.
This is how I am increasingly seeing it.
Send me a tweet at D Pacman.
Leave me a reply as a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube,